bonjour bienvenue du championnat du
monde 2016 entre blonde de tenant du
titre magnus carsen et son challenger
sérieux écart à keynes et les tie-breaks
troisième partie du tie break
donc après le match en 12 parties à
égalité qu'arsenal chaud il est revenu
donc dans la 10e après avoir perdu la
huitième donc vraiment là juste à temps
avant le 2 dernière partie réussi à
égaliser et maintenant donc les joueurs
vont devoir se départager en tie break
donc en partie rapide qu'à parties
rapides et deux premiers ont été nulles
sergueï kaliakine à l'eiblen il est
passé pas loin de la défaite lors de la
partie précédente ou carsen a obtenu
deux fous contre une tour dans une
partie de type forteresse où les noirs
en russie a établi une forteresse mais
ils étaient ils sont passés à deux
doigts de perdre car ce n a raté un un
gain un quasi match en toute fin de
partie mais c'est des parties rapides on
peut on peut lui pas dû tenir rigueur de
ça évidemment quand il reste 30 secondes
un pendule c'est pas facile donc là
c'est parti
dans cette troisième donc les joueurs
sont à égalité carrés qui n'avait blancs
eux quatre ils ne varient pas eu cinq
cavaliers 3 qu'avait laissé six fours b5
on peut dire que la suite dans les idées
toujours la même et qu'arsène insiste
aussi eric à 6 soit 4 qui arrive si cela
même pour l'instant que la première
partie du départage de ce tie-break
fawcett
des trois c'est exactement la même b5
foulée 3 des 6 à 3 ça change pas et la
petit rock carré c3 et maintenant voilà
cariat cinglante dans la précédente il
avait joué que les buts mais j'avais dit
que peut-être quelqu'un qui tue plus
précis mais bon en face au no jouer à
des micro détails mais c'est vrai que là
on oblige le foie jouer et on peut jouer
ces cinq qu'avec ses 6 ans 8 bon ben ça
fait une petite différence
x 2 x 6 voilà tout de suite les noirs
veulent échanger se fout puissant là et
sont prêts à doubler les pions pour sa
b4 qu'elle et ses 6 il revient car scène
carrée à kinsuka validé 5 1
ça ça change un peu hein voilà il faut
pas les autres variantes qui a décidé
c'est un peu nouveau sa aimé le carré au
centre pourquoi pas et les noirs font de
même ici calais des quatre cas les
dégâts se propose de s'échanger contre
kf3 les blancs joue cavalier g5 attaque
le fourneau 6 vous prend puis on prend
quelle était cette attention un tacle
ici attention on attaque le cavalier gsm
ou un cavalier 4 tension on invite les
noirs a joué cinq ici ça c'est un peu
tôt quand même on laisse les noirs
prendre de l'espace ici comme ça on
n'était pas obligé de perdre du temps
comme ça inquiète les deux ans pourquoi
pas et la s4 est bien bien joué je pense
parce que l'idée ici c'est que les
blancs eux mêmes pourraient jouer quatre
ensuite joué kf3 reprendre du fou ou
reprendre la tour tout simplement et en
laissant dix ans nous aurons un petit
peu la colonne e au lieu de quoi ce sont
les noirs qui joue f406 ns2 idée un jus
une superbe chaîne de pions là qui vise
le roi blanc donc avantage à les droits
ici on voit bien cette chaîne de pions
pousse les noirs attaque et de ce côté
là et en même temps je libère la case f5
pour les bleus cavalli qui va pouvoir
revenir et qui va être menaçant de venir
h4 attaqué le roi et voilà on peut jouer
f3 aussi attention voilà c'est
intéressant pression la pression sur les
blancs ces trois on oblige le cavaliere
partir mais parce que sinon la la menace
noir c'est de jouer froid ici bien sûr
qu'ils cassent complètement leur ok donc
ces trois voies la qualif 5 et on
revient au 4bis d'annoncer le
désavantage d'un joueur
4 c'est qu'on ne contrôle plus la
cazotte leucate lequel il peut y revenir
tranquillou
dames 1 8 treillet jouer très joli coup
à noter regarder encore une fois la dame
et sur la couleur opposée de celle du
fou et quand on a comme fou c'est
souvent sa meilleure couleur de cases
pour la dame
il remplace en quelque sorte l'autre fou
pour contrôler les cases de diagonale de
l'autre couleur le venir angers 6 et
faire pression bien sûr toujours sur le
rock food et 3 pour les blancs alors
quelle idée de fou b3 sans doute de
pouvoir je torah de nos certaines
variantes et on n'est jamais sûr mais ça
peut être l'idée aussi peut-être de
jouer à 4 et de reprendre du fou c'est
possible aussi
mais tour à deux comme ça je défends
latéralement l'un en cas où mais parce
que ça ressemble presque à un schéma
destin diène 7 cette position de but
mais qui a passé six foulées 7 c'est
rien à voir mais mais ça ressemble un
petit peu dans l'idée quand même les
loirs la voilà
attaque côté roy et on peut défendre
latéralement ce qui arrive souvent aussi
les schémas espagne et madame g6 voit la
petite pression f3 voilà regard des f3
donc j'ai libéré sept a traversé donc
plus tard je pourrais protéger la la
tour pour être à la fois actif sur la
colonne à et en même temps être
protectrice sur cette rangée noter c'est
important ça fouette 4 ça c'est
intéressant ça met la pression quand
même ça contrôle des cases vont pas
jouer tôt on peut pas jouer dans le vin
alors on sait pas ce qu'il fait là le
fou et il est présent tout cas ils
empêchent et on va les blancs n'ont pas
envie de juger trois c'est sûr je dis
n'importe quoi il n'empêche pas du tout
mais peut-être dans cet incendie peut
venir en g3 se sacrifier ce que puis on
prend pions prend et on est un pion et
standing protégé il suffit de vous les
dommages cinq essais maths ça va vite
donc à quatre les blancs ces petits
beldame il faut un parce que sinon la
côté droit là pour l'instant ils sont
peu un peu à la ramasse
attention ça se bat cela les pièces
encore une pièce qui arrivent ils
peuvent venir h c est qu on peut venir
se sacrifier ici reprendront g3 avec du
puy du fou et faire un match 2 il faut
faire attention dans me2 voilà nos deux
à cinq
noir contre attaque à l'aide alors ça
c'est fort on arrive à pouvoir attaquer
des deux côtés ça veut dire qu'on est à
l'aise et puis on prend la partie est
tendue
si on prend b4 et food et 2 les bleus en
profitent pour ceux qui veulent y
changer des pièces se libérer si on
échange des tours peut-être la taxe sera
sans doute bien moins forte
à noter quand même la triste opposition
de ce fou qui veulent bloquer par son
propre pions qu'il a eu à des pions sur
blanc partout là donc il a pas vraiment
d'action dans le camp ennemi les
défensives quoi un peu un peu penaud
puis on prend ces trois [ __ ] en c3 les
nantis davantage là cette structure de
pions et pas bonnes en dépit ou doubler
des purs isolés ici sont sous pression
d'edouard en échange ils ont par contre
une superbe chaîne de pian et en plus
tous les pions sont liés donc il ya il
ya trois îlots contre les blancs dans
des pions doublé contre 2,0 pour les
noirs structurellement les noirs sont
mieux ils ont une grosse pression aller
loin et ils sont pas mal à l'aise côté
elle dame il semblerait il semblerait
que les noirs et réussit ici à avoir une
position avantageuse dans cette
troisième partie du tie break
car veille 3 ça ça fait mal aussi attac
la tour un cavalier dans le camp ennemi
calais kathak g2 ne peut pas attention
faut commencer à voir des menaces là
peut pas faire n'importe quoi mais les
blancs faut faire très attention torcéen
tout reprend vous prendront tour prend
de tout reprendre sergueï kaliakine ici
dans huit hommes attention petite
pression ici pourquoi il fait d'un 8
alors il veut peut-être aussi une des
idées ce type de position
ça peut être activé à tour ici donc il
s'est passée la tour ici et là angers 6
ou à acheter ça peut être parfois une
idée voilà est bon en attendant on
attaque aussi des scènes tout simplement
donc les blancs protège ok et la 1re
suite voilà je suis on enlevait la dame
ici donc ici les noirs ont une plan
destin indienne classique donc g8 g5 g4
prises et ses matches voilà qu'on se
fait maths et je vous passe les détails
mais en retour j'ai vite et ont ajouté 5
g callen on en avait la dame un peu pour
ça qu'elle prend vous prévoyez il
reprend du fou mais pas de la tour on ne
veut pas mettre la tour devant il veut
bien pousser ses pions ou éventuellement
tour à 3,1 kubisa aura trois ans c'est
parce qu'elle fera trois la tour la haye
huit ans à 2 n'aurait compris qu'elle
reprotéger la deuxième rangée à trois je
sais pas peut-être les blancs veulent
jouer le tour à damas 2e mais on oui bah
non parce que à 8 et protégé donc il y
avait déjà deux pièces lourdes
je sais pas ça et là alors la superbe
chrono car cette voie là moi je la fois
du champion du monde est pour comprendre
ça moi je réponds je n'aurais pas fait
ce coup là il faut le voir quand même
enfin tout cas il donne du jeu
regardez super même eu 4 mhz alors y'a
pas de menace directe gagnante
enfin il ya des menaces mais papa
gagnante mais un jour tu auras 3g
protéger le fou on peut changer se fout
on peut mais active et la dame sur cases
noires on a un super beau cavalier
si on sait sur qui on échange le fou de
cases noires sky est intouchable c'est
pas le foot est blanche kibaki valentina
l'embêter donc les noirs un avantage
durable avec espèce de gros gros gros
gros point de blocage à un an le camp
ennemi là ce caillou 3 qui est quand
même colossal voilà donc si les bleus
arrivent pas les changer on comprend
même sens sans calculer c'est pas que
c'est pas une bonne affaire
voilà que les quelques les blancs vont
souffrir e4 sacrifices depuis
cette fois noté donc les blancs prennent
ils qu'ils acceptent ce sacrifice faut
prendre prend et simplement à la dame
s'est libéré aussi la case de 5
j'ai remplacé le fou par l'adam la dame
peut pénétrer dans le camp ennemi j'ai
le cavalier 3 qui est super menaçant
jade verte a plus fous ces quatre là
tout va pouvoir s'activer
c'est craignos alors ici qu'est ce qui
se serait passé sur tours à 3 qui semble
le bon coup pour empêcher tour à 8 bien
sûr d'accord regardez tout simplement
il est très bon très fort qu ici des
noirs regardez gagne en un seul coup paf
d'un des quatre regarder pourquoi
j'attaque le fou avec la dame et le
cavalier donc il faut enfin il faut
faire quelque chose il faut bouger le
protéger et après une découverte
donc je prends au jeu et notamment je
peux aller en ces deux échecs de la dame
et j'ai gagné à tour voilà donc donc ça
craint on pourrait jouer ici tour à 4
imaginons qu'on joue tu auras 80e je
protège le fou les gens pêche la prise
de ça il ya quand même échec cavale et
prend et ses échecs
leroy bouge il faut bouger en
je serai sans doute et on se dit veulent
travailler perdu l'un puisqu'il est
cloué et non parce qu'il ya dame ces
trois dames c3 surtout reprend il suffit
tout et âme à un chèque il éprouve pas
protégé ya un couloir droit et le
royaume voilà l'autre coup c'est de
jouer royaume est roi et fins ça doit se
marche pas parce qu'il aurait calé des
deux échecs il la tour est perdu donc
voilà donc ici sur d'un médecin qu'on
peut pas jouer tu auras trois concepts
qu'il faut jouer ce que je qualifie une
tour c1 est là mais du coup le problème
c'est très vite voilà alors là sans
calculer sans calculer on peut se dire
que les noirs sont peut-être pas gagnant
parce que on sait jamais mais on peut
dire qu'ils ont tout quoi les blancs ne
sont que passifs et ils ont de grandes
grandes difficultés les noirs vont
pouvoir pénétrer en quatre ans à 3
mètres la d'amendé 4 ou bouger de
l'autre côté le cavalier quand même
empêche les blancs de manoeuvrer comme
ils veulent
c'est l'horreur les blancs se met une
petite fenêtre en écosse 3 h 6 min noir
tranquille courage deux hommes des 4
dames 1 dames b2 attention dame b2
menace matt déjà voilà oulala ça craint
sacre un fouet fin où on vient vite vite
vite protéger la très bien et la tour à
deux menaces cavaliers projet 2 suivi
d'un match rapide de la tension donc
tout reprend c'est cette grosse erreur
de kayak inattention ici il y avait
encore un peu suite et de s'en sortir
avec tours b 1 voilà il fallait jouer
tourbe et un tombe est jouable attaque
la dame voit la dame en fait le problème
c'est que les malades ne peut pas garder
la dame sur la deuxième séance échangés
mais si on s'échange les blancs peuvent
encore s'en sortir si j'en ai deux d'un
printemps reprend après j'ai pu
déboucher le fou ou non même pas je
laisse le fou là d'ailleurs geste fou là
et puis bon je sais pas j'ai c'est de
jouer h 4 orages 3 donc j'essaie
j'active gc d'activer un peu mon jeu on
peut qu'on s'en sortir mais qu'on va
souffrir encore aller noir reste mieux
bien et bien entendu mais on peut on
s'en sortir comme ça mais là il fait une
grosse erreur là cariat quinapril fouet
f1 t'auras deux menaces attention donc
car les projets 2 et il fait tout
reprend ses sept
il prend le pian et là c'est la cata et
faites vous là même tout garcia lorca
les projets de gagne aussi les projets
de tout simplement sur foucras yadin
promat et si si les noirs et les blancs
font pas ça ils sont nus sont dominés
mais encore plus fort voilà tout
simplement opte aura un terminé tu auras
un terminée puisque le fou va tomber il
faut que la dame saint die n'a pas
d'endroit plus où elle va en plus là
c'est pas facile
en deux ans encore en deux petits
protégés par le fougueux la scala youri
cavaliers prend échec alors pôle rh
quatre rallyes on regarde ce qu'est ce
qui se passe sur damas quatre dames h4
ici à mathon regarder car les prend en
échec donc le roi peut pas aller en g3
officiel pions et le cavalier seul
suffit les rois à descendre on voit vite
que c'est matt donc roger en cavale et
j'ai trois échecs de la tour on est
obligé de venir en h2 et enfin tourache
un math
voilà ce qui explique qu'après tours 1
eh bien les blancs abandonne tout
simplement et donc arsène prend
davantage au monde à un moment archi
décisif avec les noirs en plus il reste
plus qu'une partie rapide où il suit il
lui suffit de faire partie nulle pour
devenir enfin pour garder en fait son
titre de champion de monde pour rester
le 16e champion du monde de l'histoire
un échec depuis steinitz en 1886 on n'y
est pas il reste encore une partie mais
on sent que ça sent bon pour le
norvégienne dont c'est l'anniversaire ce
jour où il joue ce tie break a tout de
suite sur des modèles tv pour la
quatrième et peut-être peut-être
dernière partie de ce fantastique
championnat du monde 2016